This quiz is going to require a little bit of guess work,
for how a multiple assignment works.
I think you'll be able to bet the right answer.
You can also try experiments in the Python interpreter.
The question is for any variable--so let's assume s and t are names,
and they've been assigned some value,
and now we execute the statement s, t assign t, s.
What does that do?
The choices are nothing--after the assignment
s and t both have the same value as they did before.
That it makes both s and t refer to what the original value of t was before this statement.
That it swaps the values of s and t so after the statement,
s now has the previous value of t and t has the previous value of s.
Or it's an error.